warum namens luca und herzlich
willkommen wir heute meine damen und
herren zu einem neuen video auf meinem
kanal ihr seht es bereits im titel und
zwar reagiere ich heute zum fünften mal
auf die lustigsten schüler antworten die
schüler wirklich in irgendwelchen tests
etc gebracht haben und ich würde sagen
wir fangen an der stelle auch schon
direkt an mit der ersten schüler antwort
die mir ausgesucht hat und zwar es ist
diese hier im original steht dort misses
ex guckt something dallas leigt und
übersetzungen die einen schüler darauf
gegeben hat ist miss asics hat dennis
likes gekuckt also 10 14 punkte die
nächste lustige schüler antwort stammt
aus der siebten klasse eines gymnasiums
und zwar ist es wieder haben eine
englisch aufgabe und zwar ist die
aufgabe frage den englischen
austauschschüler ob er vegetarier ist
der schüler antwortet daraufhin you fm
stippel bist du in obst ja an der
nächsten lustigen schüler antwort geht
es zur abwechslung mal nicht um eine
englisch aufgabe oder eine antwort auf
englisch sondern es geht um griechische
götter und zwar soll der schüler drei
griechische göttinnen oder götter
benennen und effekt ganz gut an
er sagt was richtig ist er sagt poseidon
was auch immer sagt der hepatitis
ja und dann gibt es auch hepatitis a
hepatitis b aber würde ich meine wir
müssen die schüler die diese antworten
gegeben haben auch so ein bisschen in
schutz nehmen ich meine die waren alle
irgendwie ein klasse 5 bis 10 oder
irgendwie so also dass man auch ein
bisschen jünger
allerdings machen wir direkt weiter mit
der nächsten aufgabe und zwar geht es um
eine definition und zwar ist die aufgabe
definiert den begriff archäologie und
ich glaube es gibt darum dass man dinge
aus der vergangenheit dann neu an
die antwort die der schüler gebracht hat
geht auf jeden fall auch schon wieder
gut los war sagt der archäologie
beschäftigt sich mit kunden aus
vergangener zeit zum beispiel fund von
özil
ich glaube
er meinte erziehen aber es ist nah dran
dass jetzt die nächste frage die in
einem test der klasse 6 gestellt wurde
und zwar warum wird die steinzeit
eigentlich steinzeit genannt weil steine
damals die einzigen lebensmittel waren
[Musik]
schreibt mir die kommentare wie oft ich
klatsche in diesem video unter einläuten
die ist richtig haben verlor sich
beute nenne drei stände des mittelalters
bauern adel und klitoris erkennst du
dich den klitoris stand seit der
nächsten frage geht es um das
mittelalter und zwar will der lehrer
wissen wie konnte man ritter werden und
ein schüler aus der siebten klasse
antwortet mann musste von einem bräter
geboren werden so blöd ist die antwort
der nächsten lustigen schüler antwort
fragt ein lehrer nach der
gewaltenteilung in deutschland und der
schüler antwortet nicht irgendwie mit
legislative judikative exekutive keine
ahnung was sondern er sagt pädophile
schläger und einbrecher erste frage
wurde in einer zwölften klasse gestellt
und zwar sind dort wirklich schüler der
zwölften klasse diesen älter als 17 18
jahre alt also da kann man schon mit
einer vernünftigen antwort rechnen
die frage hier ist allerdings wie kann
man eine gleichstellung von mann und
frau erreichen
die antwort ist eigentlich sind mann und
frau gleichberechtigt aber man müsste
die hausarbeit für männer attraktiver
machen beispielsweise mit einem
kostenlosen sky abo oder gutscheinen für
fußball events was jetzt die nächste
frage und zwar was ist mutterschutz der
schüler antwortet wenn die mutter ein
kind kriegt muss es nicht gleich
arbeiten hat nicht so ullrichs nenne die
aufgabe des kondoms das kondom ist da um
schlecht verkehr zu haben
er kennt sich wenn mann und frau
ganz doll lieb haben haben sie schlechte
verkehr
sowas hätte auch wirklich von mir kommen
können früher bei der nächsten aufgabe
geht es darum die unterschiede zwischen
schimpanse und mensch zu benennen ist
meiner ansicht nach eine schwierige
aufgabe oder auch in der zwölften klasse
gestellt schüler hat allerdings
geantwortet schimpansen brauchen nicht
so ein breites becken wie wir denn die
legen eier
direkt mit dir weg zur schule bei der
nächsten aufgabe geht es um biologie und
zwar die lehrerin gefordert dass man
verschiedene zelltypen im menschlichen
körper benennt und da gibt es wirklich
einige und der schüler hat sich genau
die falsche ausgesucht und zwar hat er
solarzellen gesagt
[Musik]
leute ich hoffe ich habe noch nicht
dreistellig oft geklatscht allerdings
direkt weiter mit der nächsten frage die
auf einem technischen gymnasium gestellt
wurde und zwar wozu hat der mensch
eigentlich zwei augen ja wenn er sich
eines aus sticht hat er nochmal 1 ich
schwöre bei gott ich habe bisher in
keinem video so oft geklatscht rau er
punkt hier steht strich vogel heißt das
dass das viel magersüchtig ist oder ist
das ein anderes wort für vogel nutzer
wir kennen dich auf eine mauer hamburger
reeperbahn den strich vogel bei der
nächsten aufgabe hat der lehrer
gefordert dass man drei kirchliche
feiertage benennen soll und der schüler
einer fünften klasse antwortet ostern
western und karneval
ich mein' und da bin ich ganz ehrlich
wenn ich der lehrer dort gewesen wäre
und ich würde diese fünfte klasse
unterrichten weil ich meine da muss man
sich mal vorstellen da sind die schüler
irgendwie 10 11 jahre alt und jemand
hätte das geschrieben ich hätte ihm
wirklich daneben geschrieben hey das ist
falsch
aber das war wirklich eine liste lustige
und sehr ich sollte auf keinen fall
deutsche lehrer werden bei der nächsten
frage will ein lehrer von den schülern
seiner zweiten klasse wissen also von
von von einer zweiten klasse also nicht
von seiner zweiten klasse von wegen der
hat zwei klassen sondern von der zweiten
klasse also da wo schüler wirklich 78
jahre alt sind
er will auf jeden fall wissen ob einer
von denen weiß dass eine moschee ist und
da antwortet jemand das ist bei den
mädchen da wo bei den jungen der ist
ja
das ist ja da unten da haben frauen dann
moschee ich bin immer noch ein bisschen
krank sorry aber wenn wirklich ich da
der lehrer gewesen wäre und das hat
leider geschrieben erinnerte dass allen
meinen lehrer kollegen gezeigt
ich hätte ihn ins lehrerzimmer gehangen
auf plakat die antwort der wahnsinn wir
haben kann man seine kreativität aber
als kind aufgabe nenne einen ort in
deutschland an dem es natürliche
erdgasvorkommen gibt antwort an der
tankstelle
ja
eher als
frage die einen lehrer seiner sechsten
klasse gestellt hat und zwar fragt er
warum waren die neandertaler nomaden
darauf antwortet ein schüler im winter
vor ihr gemüse ein
deshalb mussten sie weiterziehen
ja
ja das ist ja toll
jedoch allerdings wieder zu einer frage
die an eine grundschulklasse gestellt
wurde und zwar fragt der lehrer was kann
man in einer moschee finden
der schüler von vorhin hätte vermutlich
irgendetwas komisches mit der frau
geantwortet allerdings antwortet dieser
schüler eine minibar eine minibar
was versteht man unter einem
jungfernflug wenn es ein mädchen zum
ersten mal mit einem jungen macht dabei
fliegt das jungfernhäutchen weg
[Musik]
dass das ja das liegt dann klick dich
einfach weg kommt allerdings auch schon
meine damen und herren zur mittlerweile
schon letzten lustigen schüler antwort
fürs heutige video und zwar möchte ein
lehrer den begriff schwerindustrie
erklärt bekommen von seinen schülern und
daraufhin antwortet ein schüler der
achten klasse von einer realschule dass
es eine industrie in schwerin ist so
komplett daneben liegt da jetzt ja ein
gedicht schon hat er mich dass heute
wird jetzt allerdings auch wir hätten
meine lieben freunde wenn euch der
mittlerweile schon fünfte teil von die
lustigsten schüler antworten austesten
cetera gefallen das unbedingt einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da
haben wir letztes mal wieder die alten
teile angeguckt sich vor monaten
hochgeladen habe jedes video hat über
eine millionen aufrufe gemacht und es
kam mega gut bei euch an deswegen hat
sie mir einfach hey vielleicht habt ihr
bock auf den fünften teil wenn es euch
gefallen dann auf jeden fall gerne und
in die kommentare und schreibt mir auch
unten die kommentare wie oft sich heute
geklappt habe unter allen die es richtig
haben verlosen müllsack könnt euch dann
aussuchen ob 20 liter 35 oder 60 liter
ob plastik oder pappe ich lasse ihn euch
dann postalisch zukommen und abonniert
gerne auch mal ein kanal wenn ihre
langeweile habt und sonst ja geht raus
irgendwie golf spielen oder so
[Musik]